like i said thaw's legendary bloodlust
and wrath will be aimed at kratos and
atreus referred to disparagingly by
mimir as the biggest butchering bastard
in the nine realms thor earned his title
as one of the most powerful aesir gods
by wiping out nearly all the giants at
odin's command
now if this doesn't sound like the thor
you know i seriously recommend picking
up neil gaiman's norse mythology for a
primer on
this thor
let's just say he's uh something else
entirely is he though and speaking of
giants like i said they're not exactly
the all father odin's favorites and he
has long been at war with them he had
thor try and wipe them out and he
imprisoned his other son tyr for helping
them now we believe tear to be dead in
the first game but it looks like we're
going to be meeting him in ragnarok
the giants had their gift of foresight
and at the end of god of war kratos
uncovered a prophecy where it was
revealed that his wife was actually a
giant named lauthy not only is atreus
part giant he was also given the name
loki at birth and is somehow involved in
ragnarok so much for not getting
involved in the aco's affairs you're
next i'll rip your head off with regard
to atreus santa monica studio revealed
that like most young people he wants to
understand who he is more than anything
in this case he wants to understand who
he could be the mystery of loki's role
in the upcoming conflict is something
that detroit cannot let go of he wants
to keep his family safe but atreus also
doesn't want to stand by and do nothing
while conflict consumes the nine realms
my story doesn't end hiding in these
woods
i should be out there finding out who i
am who loki is but they're usually
bloodthirsty kratos seems to wish to
take a different path a line from the
game's description insinuates that he is
intent on helping to spare atreus from
the bloody lessons he learned from his
conflict with gods he wants to keep his
son safe above all and their
confrontation with balder has vindicated
the belief that only tragedy will come
from further entanglements with the
aesir together kratos and atreus will
have to make a choice about which path
they will take whatever they choose will
define the fate of all those living in
the nine realms as ragnarok approaches
which leads us quite nicely into combat
2018's god of war was praised for its
crunchy combat mechanics and systems and
sony santa monica has pledged to carry
forward that spirit and tradition
as a team we've worked hard to take our
learnings from god of war 2018 and
improve upon combat to feel fresh yet
familiar with god of war ragnarok one of
our main goals was to push player choice
in combat whether it's through hard
hitting combos a mastery of elements or
clever defensive tactics you will find
plenty of opportunities to fight
alongside our duo in a way that feels
uniquely expressive which is great
because not only do you have gods on
your tail but the other enemies in
ragnarok will be harsher and more varied
with kratos and atreya set to take on a
host of new creatures from across norse
mythology some of the new enemies
revealed so far include the stalker and
the drachi
whereas 2018's god of war allowed
players to visit six of the nine realms
ragnarok goes further and takes you to
all nine this includes vanaheim
svartalfheim and asgard which were not
in the first game new areas from
previous locations have been added to
ragnarok as well according to santa
monica studios exploring the realms will
take you everywhere from verdant
otherworldly jungles to intricate
subterranean mining networks this next
installment in the series will bring you
a more diverse beautiful and mysterious
variety of locations than in any other
god of war game
christopher judge and sunny soljic
returned to voice kratos and atreus
while ryan hirst who played opie and
sons of anarchy has joined the cast as
thor
leia de leon hayes plays anger border
while ben prendergast portrays tear
richard schiff will be playing odin
[Music]
returning from the 2018 game is bear
mccreary to once again compose the music
the new trailer from the playstation
showcase includes a tease of the new
tunes and according to mccreery's
twitter it includes a significant new
character theme which sounds both very
ominous and very exciting
corey barlog directed 2018's god of war
as well as 2007's god of war 2 but he's
not returning to direct the sequel
stepping in is eric williams a veteran
of the series to direct ragnarok
speaking to vgc williams said it's
always been a tradition here at santa
monica to change the directors across
the games we've had really good success
with that corey is the only repeat
director and rightfully so he's damn
good at what he does corey barlock added
the important thing for us is to be able
to get a fresh perspective each time but
also a fresh pair of legs in the sense
that you're really exhausted at the end
of finishing one of these things so
you've got to con somebody else into
doing it
now you are ready
[Music]
god of war ragnarok is planned for ps5
but it's also coming to ps4 the news of
a previous gen version was quietly
shared via a q a with hermann holst the
head of playstation studios at the
september playstation showcase sony
confirmed that ragnarok will be released
across ps5 and ps4 although there is no
word yet on any big differences between
the editions that might exist and what
about pc well this is all speculative
right now given sony's recent track
record of slowly bringing some of its
biggest playstation games to pc it does
make sense to question the possibility
for a pc version of god of war ragnarok
sony also recently acquired the pc port
specialist nix's software fueling rumors
that it might bring more of its first
party games to pc to help expand their
audience while a pc edition of ragnarok
hasn't been confirmed yet halst
mentioned in an interview on the
playstation blog that the company
continues to further invest in the pc
space but if it's anything like previous
sony releases on pc it's likely not to
come to the platform for some time if it
ever does
we'll let you know when we do
if you're interested in a
behind-the-scenes look at how the 2018
god of war was made check out our
episode of audio logs where game
director corey barlog breaks down one of
the most pivotal scenes how it was
created and the crucial gameplay
mechanic that was almost cut from the
game
and we really had to figure out how to
take the old moves and make them work
much better in this camera angle for
more god of war make sure to like this
video and subscribe and we'll catch you
next time
you'll get your answer soon enough
well some of them
[Music]
from software's games have always made
you feel small in many ways they tell
you that you're worthless a plague
ridden rat or accursed undead unfit even
to be cinders they ask you to navigate
unflinching brutal worlds and pit you
against enemies that systematically
dismantle your ego eldon ring maintains
the nail bite in combat an era of
mystery that has distinguished from
software soulsborne games but it's
elevated to new heights by the studio's
interpretation of what an open world
game can be having brought down the
first elden lord godric the breadth of
the world and the way in which from
software has applied its signature style
to an open world was on full display
reinforcing how insignificant i really
was and driving home the magnitude of
the tasks that still awaited me
standing on the edge of the cliffside in
leonia of the lakes the area beyond
godric's arena i took in the world laid
out in front of me the enormous urge
tree casting brilliant golden beams of
light onto the land that exists in its
shadow the sharp peaks of a distant
mountain that looked like claws tearing
at the sky a castle standing proudly
amidst ruins a forest blanketed in an
ominous fog it was all overwhelming and
none of the hardships i'd experienced in
demon souls dark souls bloodborne or
sakura have come close to making me feel
as small at the same time i was overcome
with excitement for what the lands
between had in store for me and all the
seemingly insurmountable battles
awaiting and it did not disappoint elden
ring is from software's crowning
achievement in world design epic in
scale and scope but what makes it
special isn't just how visually stunning
it all is or that its open world is vast
rich in detail and teeming with
possibilities instead it's how the
studio has applied its own esoteric
design principles to deliver an
experience that feels fresh elegant and
uniquely from software the game's core
pillars are built on the same strong
action and role-playing foundations as
previous titles while offering more
freedom to explore than ever before
eldon ring is an open world game
entirely in a category of its own that
delicate orchestration of highs and lows
and the build up and release of tension
that from software has mastered coupled
with the thrill of free form exploration
and discovery is an intoxicating
cocktail of game design a key part of
from software's design ethos is to strip
down to the essentials and in elden ring
that process strengthens exploration and
discovery the heart and soul of the
experience the studios games typically
give the player very little while asking
a lot an elden ring is the most obtuse
and demanding of his game so far this is
largely because everything you've come
to expect from modern day open world
games is absent for instance there's no
map until you find an item that reveals
the topography of a region even then the
points of interest in that region aren't
marked until you've been there and seen
them there is no mini-map just a compass
that shows the cardinal directions and
any waypoints you've placed areas you go
to won't be gated depending on your
level there's no clear indication on
when you should go to key locations the
best you get is at the sites of grace
which function as rest points in the
same way that bonfires lanterns or idols
did in other titles at each of these
sites is a dim trail of golden light
pointing in the general direction of
something perhaps it's the next
milestone on your quest or maybe it's
just another area that has a dungeon the
only way to find out is to make the
journey the challenge for from software
lies in the friction between the
studio's design hallmarks and the
expected conventions of a genre filled
with games that try to be all things to
everyone and although the execution is
an unmitigated success one thing's for
sure eldon ring is not a smooth edged
one-size-fits-all kind of experience
that will accommodate everyone instead
it's unrelentingly opaque relishes in
the savagery of confronting players with
unfavorable odds and delights in
watching the ensuing struggle elden
ring's gameplay will feel familiar to
those with experience of previous from
software games the tried and true
formula of measured third person combat
against enemies that are swift to punish
full holiness is both as thrilling and
as nerve-wracking as ever from software
has added some new gameplay wrinkles to
its soul's bone formula this time most
notable is a jump which has been pulled
out from the more dynamic movement style
of sakura this is useful not just for
traversal but also for performing a
leaping strike that can break through an
enemy's defense and create a critical
strike opportunity another new mechanic
is the ability to strike back after
blocking an enemy's attack with a heavy
counter dealing a good amount of damage
the heavy counter has some of the
satisfaction of bloodborne's gunshot and
visceral combo though it's not as
gratifyingly dramatic while it's easy to
rely on it a great deal of strategy is
still needed to perfectly execute it as
an enemy's quick follow-up strike could
cut you down before you've initiated the
counter the new gameplay mechanics
certainly provide more options against
tough foes but they still require the
player to know their opponent and
carefully select their moments the last
major addition is spirit ashes which
allow the player to summon upgradeable
ai controlled fighters to their side of
course there are restrictions around
summoning them as spirit ashes can only
be used in specific locations and only
once per life they're also susceptible
to being killed by more powerful enemies
making them better equipped for pulling
aggro than securing victories these kind
of thoughtful tweaks extend to the
checkpointing system which is a little
more lenient to accommodate the open
nature of the game instead of being
returned to a site of grace when killed
the open world is littered with small
statues called stakes of marika these
can usually be found around particularly
challenging areas whether that's because
there's a group of enemies in a
fortified location or a singular
miniboss that must be faced in one of
the many heart-pounding soul-crushing
and utterly confidence-destroying
encounters this addition is more of a
necessity for taking out the
frustrations of having to travel large
distances in an open world the
challenges the stakes of america precede
are no less forgiving elden ring is
undoubtedly difficult much harder than
any of from software's previous games
and while a great deal of that is owed
to the challenging bosses and enemies a
significant amount is also because of
the freedom the game offers the player
it doesn't tell you where to go in any
way so it can be very easy to find
yourself in places that are too
difficult for you to navigate instead it
just trusts you to assess the situation
and consider your own capabilities both
as a player and a character then decide
if you should return to a place that is
more manageable and continue building
your character up to come back later
some like me will fall hopelessly in
love with the thrill of blindly
wandering into a corner of the map and
being ruthlessly murdered for hours on
end just to walk away with little more
than the satisfaction that i kept
picking myself up and eventually emerged
victorious albeit battered and bruised
others however will find the idea of
navigating a perilous catacomb down to
its deepest depth while braving all
manner of horrifying creatures just for
a few measly crafting materials to be
the epitome of unrewarding but either
way there's a boldness to the approach
that deserves to be respected the lands
between is no less content rich than
many of its open world contemporaries
and it offers much to do in fact it's an
immensely large game that is bursting
with activities to undertake in the
starting area of limb grave alone there
are numerous caves tunnels ruins
catacombs shacks and encampments to find
these may not always lead to meaningful
progress in becoming an elder lord or
advancing a key questline but none of it
felt superfluous or boring this is
because what these activities offer is
far more meaningful a gameplay loop that
sparks a curiosity to uncover the
secrets that the lands between hold and
the raw satisfaction of discovery
discovering things to do is as intensely
satisfying as doing them and that is
what eldon ring is predicated upon the
same sense of growth and satisfaction
that comes from conquering lord ran or
becoming completely at home in yharnam
is present as you brave the lands
between what once struck fear into your
heart becomes trivial as you venture
deeper and spend ruins to level up and
grow stronger it shouldn't come as a
surprise that a from software game isn't
quick to dish out rewards and praise for
tasks you undertake instead the most
valuable rewards are intangible and
internal a sense of personal growth that
comes from your mastery of mechanics and
domination of the world's vicious
denizens or the feeling of journeying
through this inhospitable land as a
cartographer poking into its various
nooks and crannies and seeing what lurks
there there are countless moments that
will catch you off guard and fuel that
desire to explore on one occasion i
traveled to a remote shack where a war
master had taken up residence he had
always been there but this was my first
time visiting at night and he wasn't in
the shack when i approached it a cloud
of red appeared and from within a night
menacingly stepped out to do battle it
proceeded to wipe the floor with me but
considering it was telekinetically
wielding a large spectral blade i'd say
it had a bit of an advantage this was
one of many moments just like it that
made my mind race with possibilities
with the world as vast as the land
betweens that shifts dramatically
depending on the time of day what else
was out there for me to see elden ring
is a game where the possibilities feel
endless and i felt driven to chase them
all down as each one offers a memorable
moment and made the world feel richer
freeform exploration isn't completely
new and the proverbial elephant in the
room in that regard is the legend of
zelda breath of the wild it's easy to
draw comparisons between elder ring and
nintendo's acclaimed open world zelda
but what sets the two apart is a greater
sense of authorship around the things
that you can stumble upon in the lands
between and an overall cohesion between
the open world and these activities
elden ring is seamless whether you're
delving into a cliffside cave or
breaching a massive castle front and in
spite of the vast diversity amongst
these locations although there are
occasional breaks to make a transition
these are just for a few specific set
piece locations that are elaborate
dungeons with ambitious design ideas
think of it as going from hemwick
channel lane to cainhurst castle in
bloodborne while the open world
represents a newer soulsborne gameplay
experience that prioritizes freedom and
player agency there are also numerous
key locations that are more in line with
the enclosed directed areas of previous
games stormville castle redmayne castle
and raya lucaria among others are where
from software continues to do what it
does best create visually arresting
locations that are intricately designed
to loop and weave in on themselves in a
way that makes navigating through them
as joyous as it is perilous each of the
key locations in the game has a distinct
atmosphere aesthetic and vibe and i
found it impossible not to marvel at the
craftsmanship on show this is the kind
of game where you have to stop to see
the sights even when the sights are
grotesque creatures that make you worry
about the minds that created them there
are areas of elder rings world that feel
as genuinely terrifying as bloodborne
like caled where the river runs the
color of copper fishes erupt like
bursting arteries trees are shriveled
and curled like the hands of an ancient
witch and a blood red sky stretches as
far as the eye can see but hop on
torrent your spectral steed and ride
west to limgrave and you'll realize that
the lands between isn't entirely a world
on the brink of collapse with life about
to be snuffed out it's very much alive
and that much is evident from the
verdant fields bustling wildlife and
picturesque vistas if you're in the
right place at the right time you might
even find yourself in a moment of
serenity as the light of morning dawn
sweeps over a forest and trees gently
sway in the wind the most impressive
part of it all is how it coalesces in a
single landmass that the player can
travel across despite the fact that each
area looks and feels like it could be
from an entirely different game needless
to say elden ring is a gorgeous game and
a spectacular feast for the eyes much
has been made of george r r martin's
involvement but there's little in elden
ring that stands out as having his
fingerprints on it from the characters
to the narrative and the way it's
delivered in broken pieces for the
player to fill the gaps in it's
unmistakably hidataka miyazaki and the
from software team and it's all
fascinating to talk about it would be to
deprive you and the largest soulsborne
community of one of the greatest joys of
a new from software game so i won't do
that but it's safe to say that the
expansive world which george rr martin
helped laid the foundation for is filled
with memorable characters some have
mysterious motivations while others have
tragic fates and somber backstories
there's clashing ideologies divine
entities and clandestine groups vying
for power all the pieces and item
descriptions needed to supercharge the
from software law video industrial
complex are there i have just a small
grasp of everything going on and i
cannot wait for the larger community to
get involved so we can all piece it
together as a collective elven ring is a
game that i firmly believe was designed
to be a communal experience not because
it has online co-op but because there
are so many things in the game to
discover that it will undoubtedly
encourage speaking feverishly into the
wee hours of things seen and places
discovered the community that has
already emerged around the game reminds
me of when demon souls was first
released and players took to forums to
share their experiences and guide each
other through the game that kind of
galvanization around the game is truly
special and only possible here because
of from software's decision to pull back
on what it tells the player while
trusting that they will find their own
sense of adventure chase their
curiosities and engage in jolly
cooperation in a genre that's become
wrought with bloated and over designed
games eldon ring is defiantly contrarian
in almost every way its commitment to
design by subtraction and to placing the
responsibility of charting a path
through its world entirely on the player
makes it stand head and shoulders above
other open world titles elden ring takes
the shards of what came before and
forges them into something that will go
down in history as one of the all-time
greats
a triumph in design and creativity and
an open world game that distinguishes
itself for what it doesn't do as much as
what it does
vita means life it means to be a vita
islander it means to be a part of a cult
following that believed in this little
machine more than the makers themselves
did and i
was not one of them
cue
the booze
but that doesn't mean i wasn't always
curious i just missed the boat to vita
island a place in which many people are
still abandoned to this day everyone has
left vita island the people on vida
island are trapped on vita island so i
might be ten years late but better late
than never to see what this thing is all
about the people love so damn much
this is
10 years later
with the vita
[Music]
first my journey with evita begins with
not having one but thankfully i knew
again
hi
what are you doing with this uh i'm
making uh a 10-year retrospective from a
dude who's never played it all right i
love you bye bye
[Music]
when i finally got it in my hands i was
hoping to boot it up to a bunch of
exclusive vita games i couldn't play
anywhere else i did not know powerstone
was on this dude
instead i was greeted with mostly ps1
games like metal gear solid final
fantasy vagrant story in castlevanias
there were the usual games i was
familiar with like danganronpa and
virtue's last reward but then there was
also persona 4 golden but why play some
beloved game like persona when i could
play the real sony flagships like
uncharted and killzone and
i admit now
that was my first mistake i booted up
uncharted gold and abyss and it
certainly looked the part but it was
also accompanied with what felt like
forced touched controls and aiming with
the back and gyro that made me feel like
an idiot
kill zone was basically the exact same
experience except the shooting wasn't
the most comfortable thing for me on
that size device i ended up doing the
claw thing quite a bit to hit the other
buttons and yeah just
i mean they certainly follow through
with that high production value sony
stamp of approval but i couldn't help
feel that these were being muzzled by
vita's gimmicky features a lot of which
had me holding and using the vita in
ways that just felt incredibly unnatural
i knew somewhere underneath these funky
controls that there were good games
i just didn't have the patience to find
them
and i mean how could i have not i've
never had this thing i never owned this
thing i just knew i had
these dual touch screens and all these
other features and functions so it was
only natural that i wanted to see what
those first-party sony developers that
are so prestigious and what they do
could do with so many
you know fun and touchy
thingama dudes
they look beautiful for what it's worth
[Music]
it wasn't until long that i naturally
just found myself turning to the games i
already knew on the device stuff like
power stone and tekken 6 and in the
process
continued to neglect persona 4 golden
despite it being installed just ready to
go staring me right in the eyes i admit
now
that is my second mistake in the matter
of days the vita had found a place at
the end of my desk where i began to
collect dust while i played other games
on my switch
one of them ironically a popular visual
novel that saw its american debut on the
vita the house and fatima ghana
my first impressions of this beloved
device at least right out of the box
were far from
enticing but i knew that what i had seen
was only a breath of what it had to
offer i knew that i was getting a very
narrow lens into this so i needed to
know more i needed the full picture i
didn't even know this thing's history
honestly the veda came out here states
in february 2012 somewhere between the
release of the 3ds and the wii u
and well i chose
the things on either side of the vita
with only one of those things
actually
doing okay out of the
full roster of that stuff sony's mission
after the incredibly successful psp was
to meld big budgeted game experiences
into the handheld and with it for some
reason packed in
was a bunch of features it had some
novel stuff like having dual analog
sticks an oled screen and gyro motion it
also had outward and inward facing
cameras and for some reason not just a
front
but a back touch screen too
still at first when it came out it was
pretty successful despite the gimmicks
it showed a promising prospect for its
future like at first yeah maybe most
people didn't understand why i needed
two touchscreens and i'm sure the back
touch screen also boosted the cost of it
being made but additionally you had to
use a proprietary ps vita memory card
which was a hidden cost for owners and
they were expensive
[Music]
while it sold okay in japan here in the
states sales began to slow down real
fast after the console's release and a
lot of the heavy hitting studios decided
to move on for the device including its
maker
sony only two years after its release
sony pivoted to try giving it multiple
uses
rather than more games like giving it
remote play for the ps4 and ps tv which
was a companion device to play vita
games on your tv the switch before the
switch except you didn't dock it still
pretty novel i i give them credit
they were like a little ahead of the
curve there
in fact 2014 was the last time the
consul got a major first party release
which was freedom wars sony's answer to
the absence of monster hunter on the
device which had seen its it's uh
that franchise live
live prosperly is that a word live
fruitfully on 3ds instead
so when the ubisofts and eas and sony
stepped out the indies stepped in and
games like ali ali hotline miami and fez
suddenly found a new home on this thing
and the people who bought it and loved
it were now tasked with carrying its
legacy despite all of its major support
abandoning them and thus the vita
islanders
were born it's over the ship is sailed
everyone has left vita island the people
on vita island are trapped on vita
island while doing research i kept
coming across the hashtag vida islanders
the hashtag spawned from the vedas
number one fan greg kinda funny miller
the king of the veda at least that's how
i view him
he's because he just loves that thing
and he'll tell you that he loves it
he'll
he'll make sure you know
you're where you where he's where you
stand with him when you haven't played
it i would know greg i'm sorry but i've
never
played the vita until now and what a
surprise where were you 10 years ago
that's when we needed you you all come
around now you're like oh it's a great
persona machine oh freedom war seemed
really cool oh my god this is where i
should have been playing hotline miami
the whole time you want a pat on the
back you want everybody to show up watch
your little video read your little
feature because 10 years you find jesus
later it doesn't help the vita is dead
and it's because of you oh
the steam deck's coming wow
i can play indies in the [ __ ]
giant game gear the veto was better than
that and you knew it was
i got
uh
i got tear away tearaway is real good
tearaway's a real good one yeah clearly
people were very passionate about this
thing and i started to fear that i would
regret at least not trying to understand
that
so
i picked it back up i began playing it
constantly in meetings while i pretended
to listen to jesse while she rambled
about playstation all-stars well we
can't be super smash brothers so you
can't knock people off the stage so
hitting people built up a meter i even
took it with me on the stationary bike
while i played gravity russian hotline
miami then i finally came around to tear
away the first game that really showed
the potential for all of vida's gimmicks
but in the best way possible it was the
only thing i played that really
demonstrated a bespoke experience only
available to the vita
[Music]
but there was still one last game on
this device that lingered in the shadows
installed and ready to go at any moment
that i knew i would have to play at one
point to truly understand what it is
that makes this console so special to so
many people so i finally booted up
persona 4 golden
playing persona 4 golden was the first
time i felt that i could really put
myself in the shoes of someone who this
device meant a lot to i'm only a few
hours in at this point but there's been
a string of murders there's this
whole concept of the midnight channel
like looking into your tv at midnight to
see possible next victim as well as this
over
arching theme of a big corporate
business coming in and hurting
independent businesses around it like
how all these things are playing into
each other i should have played this
first this is very much
a kurt thing murders detectives spooky
stuff at midnight
and you're right greg this is a
wonderful persona machine and it's not
so much just persona 4 specifically but
it's when i began really seeing what the
vita offered that other devices just
didn't at the time i picked this thing
up so fixated on trying to understand
all its features and bells and whistles
convinced i'd find some justification
for all of it but i never did but that's
because from the start i was looking in
the wrong place considering that this
game wasn't really available anywhere
else at the time i can really
imagine someone losing hours and hours
and hours to this game on this device
in their hands and i can really
kind of understand why
this would have been
special to someone why this thing would
have been important i'm getting it it's
clicking it's clicking
and that's when it really sunk in that
this thing upon its release really
didn't know what it was but its identity
in the end was informed by its players
when this thing first came out it was
supposed to be sony's answer to aaa
gaming in the mobile space but in
reality it became the indie buddy the
ps1 pale the go-to machine for none
triple a titles
something that the switches for a lot of
people today
including me
[ __ ] you
emails interrupting
god
[Music]
i don't regret waiting all this time to
have played the vita um in fact if i'm
being completely honest after i finish
persona 4 golden i don't know if i'll
ever touch this again unless someone
sends me a copy of freedom wars or touch
my katamari
then maybe i'll consider it i'm not some
vida islander all of a sudden besides i
don't think anyone that's on vita island
would want me there now
anyways but i'm glad i got to spend time
with this thing and see it beyond
what was there at face value what was
there beyond what the aaa corner of the
game industry gave it i got to see a
glimpse into
into something into a device
that was held up
by
not the big leagues but the indies by
the players
and that is what mattered like that's
what mattered looking at i know they're
all i know you're bitter and grumpy greg
that i wasn't there from the start but
now i can at least take a step back and
understand why for so many people
vita
means life
[Music]
also thank you tamar hussein for letting
me borrow this it means a lot
[Music]
horizon forbidden west casts an imposing
shadow with its sheer size and density
but it's ultimately the characters and
stories you'll encounter that will drive
you to explore its new frontier the game
is continually compelling not because
developer gorilla games filled it with a
huge amount of stuff to do but because
so much of that stuff is thoughtfully
constructed and sometimes even
emotionally engaging instead of just
feeling like items created to add as
many map markers to a world as possible
forbidden west picks up almost
immediately after the end of the
original horizon and its dlc add-on
frozen wilds and it expects you to be
very familiar with protagonist eloy's
adventures from back in 2017 it's set in
the distant future after the world as we
know it has ended and humans have
reverted to a tribalistic society
scattered across the ruins of the united
states and roaming all around the world
are giant robotic animals some as big as
dinosaurs that kill humans on site
although eloy defeated the rogue
artificial intelligence hades in the
first game the damage it did to the
planet's biosphere means she's still
hunting ancient tech to fix the problem
that takes her into the afr mentioned
forbidden west in hopes of stopping a
blight slowly crossing the land
threatening everyone with starvation
since aeloy is a hunter in a
hunter-gatherer society collecting
components to craft gear is a huge part
of the experience both for improving
your equipment and for keeping you
stocked in battle fighting huge powerful
machines is an exercise in identifying
weak points and using various kinds of
weapons and crafted ammo to strip away
armor while inflicting status effects
such as setting enemies on fire bathing
them with corrosive acid or freezing
them to make their metal bodies more
brittle
in a lot of ways forbidden west is
pretty much the same as zero dawn but
follows the common sequel ethos of more
and bigger and a lot of the systems have
been improved and expanded along the way
the horizon games include climbing and
environmental puzzles like those you'd
see in assassin's creed or uncharted but
in forbidden west much more of the world
is scalable to let you reach the tops of
mountains and ruins although this isn't
the legend of zelda breath of the wild
and you can't climb everything the
freedom still improves traversal quite a
bit however as does a powered grapple
that you can use to reach specially
marked points a glider that lets you get
down from those high places quickly and
the ability to swim and explore
submerged environments your arsenal is
larger with a bunch of different kinds
of weapons and elemental ammo types for
straight combat plus a series of
craftable traps that you can use to take
down machines and enemies before they
spot you and have a chance to fight back
there are so many weapons and options
that at times it's hard to keep it all
straight six huge skill trees replace
zero dawn's more modest four and each
focuses on a single element of eloy's
arsenal like traps hacking ranged combat
or stuff the skills you can unlock
include passive buffs and active special
moves for each weapon type
there's also a new set of powerful valor
abilities that feel similar to an
ultimate you might see in something like
overwatch or apex legends one valor
ability lets you turn on active
camouflage to go invisible and escape a
bad situation another amps up your
ability to slice off machine parts with
your weapons a third just creates a
blast of electricity around you to send
enemies flying
you can only equip one valor ability at
a time once you've unlocked it and you
have to charge it up through combat in
order to use it again it is a lot of
stuff to keep track of and the sheer
volume works against forbidden west as
often as it works for it for instance
you can buy weapons at every settlement
and each has a confusing name like shock
warrior bow or vanguard hunter bow most
of the time though it's not super clear
whether the uncommon shredder launcher a
merchant is selling is an upgrade over
the uncommon shredder launcher you
already have with so many ammo types in
the game you wind up carrying a bunch of
weapons to cover all the elemental bases
while not really caring about any one of
them it's only late in the game when you
start to find some demonstrably sick
weapons that the arsenal feels like
anything more than just a pile of junk
in your backpack that you have to dig
through until you find a bow that shoots
the right kind of arrows for a given
situation the massive skill tree
presents the same problem valor
abilities can be great in a pinch giving
you some next level power when you
really need it but there are two to
unlock on each skill tree and the use
cases for some aren't nearly as clear as
emergency invisibility cloak or 30
seconds of souped-up arrows the same
goes for the huge number of special
abilities which amounts to three for
each weapon type some are game altering
strategy centerpieces like the knockdown
shot but others are easy to forget about
like a skill that makes your slingshot
bomb more powerful if it bounces on the
way to your target in both cases you'll
probably unlock one or two you like and
stick with those for most of the game
that's also an issue with the flow of
combat forbidden west gives you more
options in a fight but it doesn't really
change battles fundamentally from zero
dawn it just throws more ingredients
into the stew you'll usually sneak into
a situation where a bunch of robots or
humans are gathered moving from tall
grass patch to tall grass patch to
either set traps snipe enemies or pull
off sneaky executions
once you've tipped off the machines to
your presence though combat can feel
flaily enemies have a tendency to attack
quickly and relentlessly and your only
defensive recourse is a dodge roll to
get out of harm's way so when a scrapper
or a wide mod charges you're dodging
attack after attack hoping to get a
little distance to draw an arrow and get
a shot off before you go back to fleeing
for your life it's also frustrating
trying to dig through your stupidly
large bag of traps and potions to find
an item that can heal you or cancel
status effects as again you're being
chased down by an apartment
building-sized predator aloy has so much
gear and so many options at all times
that a lot of forbidden west's good
ideas about combat stealth trapping and
crafting get in the way of one another
but when you're able to make aloy's
various tools and abilities come
together it creates some harrowing and
exciting battles that's especially true
when you're able to make a plan with
stealth traps and tactics and execute it
it helps that while you fight a lot of
battles alone quite a few encounters
will see you aided by other characters
having an extra bow and more targets for
machines to chase lessens the pressure
and characters routinely chuck aloy
extra ammo to keep the fight going it's
those other characters that will keep
you going through forbidden west as much
as the opportunity to explore a
fascinating ruin or fell a rampaging
robo t-rex often you'll meet up with
someone from a local tribe who has a
vested interest in checking out that
long dormant agricultural testing
facility or space travel research lab
and it's in building relationships with
those characters and learning about
their various peoples that forbidden
west really shines even if eloy herself
is kind of dull forbidden west puts eloy
in an almost mass effect style position
of building a team to help her save the
world about a third of the way into the
game you establish a stable base of
operations and characters both old and
new become mainstays you don't bring
them out into the field as a unit like
an rpg team but you can head back to
talk with them about what you learn and
your experiences and they'll often pair
up with you at key moments or ask your
help with side quests that are important
to them the group grounds forbidden
west's story and gives you a foothold in
local events side quests are also
populated by interesting people with
relatable problems and motivations it'll
blow all the others out of the forge
you have got to help me
and forbidden west does a great job of
giving you things to do that don't feel
like repetitions of the open world go
here get this quest template often side
quests involve several steps or multiple
missions forcing alloy to intervene in
local politics or help with a dire
situation and they're not always about
combat in one series of missions you
wind up interacting with the leaders of
two desert villages each with differing
views about the future of the tribe and
distrusting of the other both are
likable but flawed characters and as you
spend a little time helping and getting
to know both you realize that neither is
wholly right or wrong the investment of
time and the solid writing adds stakes
to the situation that keep you invested
in its resolution
forbidden west is full of moments where
the game goes out of its way to put you
in close contact with a side character
for a bit and then turns them into the
fulcrum of an interesting quest paired
with the stakes of the main story this
gives the whole game the feeling that
you're not just running around doing
errands and odd jobs you're actually
building important relationships with
people you've come to know and respect
and while there are an absolute
truckload of side quests plus smaller
jobs to do many are well written and
offer a deeper look into forbidden
west's world gorilla is also usually
good at keeping its various map-filling
activities feeling fresh and diverse
looks like this door's locked
maybe there's another way in the game
contains a number of relic ruin sites in
which you explore a decrepit ancient
building looking for an artifact locked
in a hard to reach place there are a
bunch of these but i stopped to do each
one because they're fun and complex
climbing puzzles and they're all very
distinct from one another the same goes
for the tallnecks the giant robot
dinosaurs that serve the map revealing
function of towers in other open world
games reaching the top of each lumbering
robot is a puzzle unto itself
one is submerged in the ocean and
requires you to find components to
rebuild it for instance and another
can't be reached until you knock it over
by shooting it with giant ballistas the
general goal is always to get to the top
of a tall neck but each challenge is so
different from the others that they're
absolutely worth chasing down as soon as
you reach a new area
to other machines
but now it's mine the main story also
has its share of standout moments one
portion concerns helping the leader of
the tanakh to put down a rebellion so he
can make attempts at peace and
cooperation with the tribes in the east
another takes you into a submerged
underground las vegas strip to help some
salvagers realize their dream of
elevating their traveling storytelling
act with technological wonders the story
can be uneven at times but it's often
good at keeping the focus on stakes that
feel like they actually matter to the
people involved the storytelling is
aided by the fact that forbidden west is
absolutely gorgeous on playstation 5 in
both its graphics and its performance
mode everything from the characters and
their intricately constructed armor to
the rusting ruins of cities with rebar
jutting out of concrete to the lush
jungles and windswept deserts is
impressively detailed catching a sunrise
over the farms of plain song or the
waves of landfall is legitimately
beautiful and the colorful diverse
locations offer vista after stunning
vista everywhere you look it's a very
pretty game
characters benefit from a great deal of
strong voice work and what seems like an
abundance of scanned facial performances
if not outright full motion capture with
a hose to a compressed air capsule
hammer and tongue what is this what is
happening here what
get over here you'll spend a large
amount of time in conversations in
forbidden west and in the main quest and
big side quests the characters are often
compelling because their facial
performances are so good this has a
drawback though you'll definitely notice
the less important folks who move like
animatronics and in some interactions on
lesser missions eloy has a tendency to
look all over the place as if her
animation isn't quite matched to that
particular conversation or circumstance
maybe i can help
for the big important moments though a
ton of characterization and emotion
comes through in the faces and it makes
the stories and emotional beats of the
game all the more interesting the vast
size of forbidden west also feels like
it introduces a fair few technical
issues beyond alloy's occasional
inability to make eye contact with less
interesting characters especially when
you're on a mount or looking over large
distances there can be some texture pop
in particularly with the architecture of
settlements the game crashed to the
playstation dashboard on me a handful of
times as i played through it and a
couple of times a quest couldn't be
completed until i reloaded an earlier
save aloy got stuck looting a chest or
an enemy a few times forcing me to roll
back to an earlier save and she got
stuck in the sky and in the ground on a
couple of occasions too none of these
issues were game breaking for me and
forbidden west auto saves liberally so i
never lost much if any progress a day
one patch seems to have ironed out a few
of the pre-release issues i experienced
but while some of them have been
lessened like the texture pop-in problem
they haven't been
eliminated overall though horizon
forbidden west does a lot more right
than it does wrong it might be
jam-packed with stuff to see do know and
remember but when its many systems come
together it can be a beautiful exciting
and delightful open world experience the
story that drives you through the
frontier is often well told and does
well to center actual characters rather
than audio logs and while the map is
littered with icons it's much more often
that they're fun skillfully crafted
diversions than random busy work to fill
a checklist there's a huge amount to see
and do and horizon forbidden west and
the great majority of it is worth doing
and seeing thanks to strong writing
great visuals and some marked
improvements to the series underlying
ideas
[Music]
[Music]
this is lucy james reading for reviewer
alex [ __ ] in gran turismo 7 the latest
entry in the playstation's top flight
race series perfection isn't only famed
producer kazunori yamauchi's aim it
swiftly becomes yours it's been a
quarter of a century since the real
driving simulator that got petrol heads
obsessed with lap times on the ps1
released and it hasn't evolved massively
for better and for worse it's strangely
familiar but it plays as close to
driving a real car as you can get on a
console and draws you in with challenges
physics and luscious visuals
gran turismo's goal to be the best
looking driving sim out there hasn't
been dropped there are two display modes
to choose from scapes mode and frame
rate mode on a ps5 connected to a 4k tv
with ray tracing enabled escapes mode
becomes a visual treat for snap happy
players and fans of custom creations
everything looks smooth enough that
you'll want to run your fingers across
the glistening paint jobs however when
you're racing you'll want to have frame
rate mode switched on this keeps the
game at a steady 60 frames per second
but does lose some visual flair how much
you'll care about that may be limited as
when you're racing you'll likely only
have eyes for the car in front not how
accurate the reflection of the
advertisements your blitzing past is on
the hood
even without retracing the hyper
detailed in-car view shows bits of the
dashboard reflected in the windshield
drawing your eye it can be a bit
distracting but that's how real cars
work
gran turismo 7's 420 plus car models are
staggering not a switch out of place nor
an incorrect line to my experienced eyes
if you're into staring at cars you
really can't go wrong sniffing around
brand central the in-game location where
you buy the majority of gt7s cars it's
here you'll notice something a bit
strange though while each model is
impressive
many are a little on the old side the
tesla model s for example is the
original pre-facelift car why have that
when there's a fresh-faced plaid model
on sale now how come the most up-to-date
road-going mclaren you can buy in the
game the 650s went out of production
half a decade ago the cars that are
there look incredible but the vast
majority are out of date
some of the older cars are there for
good reason a classic mustang is always
a great time and belongs in gran turismo
for the sake of being awesome and saving
credits to afford a legendary aston
martin is an achievement to be
celebrated so it's not all dude wears my
car
gt7 has a charming story mode of sorts
the cafe it's here players will be
steadily introduced to all the joys the
game has to offer via lucca the cafe's
friendly owner he provides you with menu
books that set specific challenges which
unlock tracks features or cars to
bolster your collection and collect a
level which in turn increases as you
collect cars and gains you more rewards
unless the challenge is to go to a
specific place like the amusingly named
understeer tuning shop to fettle your
car or gt auto for a new wing chances
are you'll find yourself in a race to
win a car of some sort in an attempt to
humanize gran turismo polyphony's given
luca a cast of friends sarah guides you
around the gt world acting as something
of a proxy car designers will appear at
the cafe to tell you all about how great
your car is gt world tour races act as
instructors on licensed tests adding
smiles to what used to be a fairly
robotic process they're all represented
as faces in disks with text underneath
unfortunately the scripts they deliver
go from a bit clunky to i can smell the
cheese from here players will amass the
kind of car collection a millionaire
would be proud of fairly quickly but
places to drive those cars can take a
while longer to roll out because there
are fewer tracks than cars however this
ultimately is not a bad thing the tracks
take a while to learn anyway because of
this you never feel rushed to pick up
too many things too quickly though you
don't get to spend too much time with
your motors before moving on to the next
set sometimes you'll be rewarded with a
roulette ticket these seem like a neat
idea but the promise of a shiny new car
or a huge stack of credits seemed in my
case at least to be a little more than
dangled carrots to hook you the actual
prizes won being low value races go the
usual gran turismo way you start at the
back and fight your way to the front
races have a recommended pp or
performance point rating to let you know
how competitive your car needs to be by
sending whichever car you've chosen to
race to understeer and buying choice
toys you can comically overpower your
ride and pick off most of the field on
the first lap like gt games of old the
pack at the rear is easy to take a small
gap leads you to another set after
another gap you'll encounter the front
runners before having a mildly troubling
fight for first why gran turismo insists
on starting you at the back of the pack
for each race is baffling but for a
one-off race it's understandable for the
occasional championships where you win
or plays highly in a previous race that
aside the racing is still fun ai
competitors drive defensively and
occasionally make mistakes each race
does feel similar and occasionally
rubber bandy but there's enough
challenge in there to make you return
for more license tests are back and are
addictive albeit occasionally
frustrating little tasks that teach you
the game's physics model the way gran
turismo handles is as you'd hope after a
quarter of a century of refinement bang
on barrel into corners with the throttle
wide open and you'll understeer lift off
mid corner and the rear will swing round
depending on how many of the game's
myriad modifications from understeer or
gt auto you've applied it'll behave
differently but within the rules of
gt7's physics the same goes for
increment conditions not all circuits
can have dynamic weather but those that
can are a different broader kind of fun
to play on you'll first find your super
slick race tires an expensive investment
but a good way to up performance points
fast are now useless you'll then either
learn how to control a slide at speed or
where the retry button is the track will
dry eventually your palms
maybe not
night driving's a blast as are the
astronomically accurate starscapes that
keep the sky bright
while racing and collecting are the main
focus you'd be a fool to miss out on
missions these include a variety of
different driving challenges such as
slip streaming for speed drag racing or
overtaking challenging opponents in a
short slot of track like license tests
they can be frustrating but you'll keep
coming back for more similarly the music
rally function is a neat distraction
from the main game drive quick enough to
music so you don't run out of beats you
start with a set amount of beats that
decrease with each well beat of the song
you're listening to drive quick enough
and you'll pick more up via gates on the
track run out and it's game over finish
the whole song and you've won not a
reason to buy it outright but
entertaining if you want something
different there's still no obvious
damage to cars though yamauchi and the
polyphony team want racing clean so cars
don't need to get damaged but it's 2022.
if i have a prang the game should know
about it considering the level of detail
that's gone into the rest of the game it
seems like something of a cop-out to not
have any evidence of a crash even
cosmetic another thing that hasn't leapt
to the next gen is the sound 3d audio
tech means you can hear more but what
you hear isn't edge of your seat
thrilling there are plenty of places to
race in gt7 some based on real locations
some exclusive to the game with 90
layouts and over 34 tracks to earn and
explore you shouldn't find yourself
bored each track comes with its own
challenges not only in layout but in
environmental changes as well while
you'll be concentrating on a race it's a
lot more exciting when the sun's out and
the rains at bay as having more grip
tends to make winning races easier
at the time of review gt7's online mode
casual ranked or the meeting spaces
wasn't available but if polyphony's
carrying over the gt sport system we've
little to worry about all your gt sport
data will be transferred though sadly
not your garage as with gt sport you
need to have a constant internet
connection for most of the game to work
and save this says polyphony is to curb
cheating still we'll sink some time into
the online modes and update this review
to reflect our experiences
gran turismo 7 isn't a departure but
rather a newer shinier gt game its
physics model is accurate and while the
racing can be formulaic it's always a
giggle the attempt at humanity is a
little bit cringy the lack of up-to-date
cars seems like an open goal mist and
the game may not have changed
drastically but that's not the worst
thing in the world there are medals to
claim cars to collect and people on the
internet to embarrass around goodwood
the ring or well anywhere really
playstation petrol heads are in for a
good time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello viewers i am ivy the android
i'd like to share today's dinosaur
forecast
a dinosaur outbreak will soon occur
residents in the affected area have been
evacuated and a team of exo fighters has
been dispatched
a vortex warning has been issued
please remain indoors
[Applause]
[Music]
i make a sense of this situation
even if you founded the chief's records
for two years all i wanted was to be
ibs's top pilot ids's latest dinosaur
forecasts and exoc technology
were able to keep human casualties to
[Music]
zero exosuit development is proceeding
under the guidance of the next jedi
leviathan
meanwhile
ideas continues to equip candidates to
become new exo fighters
humanity's greatest hope
[Music]
[Music]
another exo fighter recruit right
welcome to ibs
state of play returns with more
announcements and updates for your
favorite games
we just saw the debut of xo primal a
brand new ip from capcom it hits ps4 and
ps5 next year
next up let's get some eye popping
updates for some fan favorites launching
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
later today visit playstation store to
download a new demo for stranger of
paradise final fantasy origin
now let's jump into the world of force
spoken with some all-new gameplay
that is quite beautiful
yeah and uh everything here wants to
kill you kind of way
you know i'm a world changer
[Music]
that's why i'm so dangerous
oh
[Music]
[Music]
let's finish this
[Music]
that was a new look at the sprawling ps5
adventure for spoken from luminous
productions
let's check out some 6v6 action in
gundam evolution a fast-paced
multiplayer shooter coming to ps4 and
ps5 later this year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kaiju brawler gigabash comes to ps4 and
ps5 later this year
next a fan favorite fighting game makes
a beautiful and bizarre return
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's
[Music]
[Music]
our next two games will take you beyond
life and death
oh
foreign
[Music]
right
ah
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
trapped
in an endless cycle
fighting
dying
returning
always the same
yet always changing
astra
i'm not alone
not anymore
now i stand
before the endless tower
i climb
as sisyphus did
pushing the boulder upward
no matter how high i climb
the challenge
begins
again
but i fight on
through the infinite
seeking answers
seeking
ascension
my release is within this tower
and i will find it
[Music]
house mark is bringing campaign co-op
and a mysterious new survival mode to
returnal ascension a free update hitting
this march
it's almost time to sign off but before
we do let's get a first look at two
brand new games coming from square enix
is this really what you want
and you are certain that what we are
doing is best for the people of the
kingdom
yes
i suppose it would in a sense
true
yes
it made me wonder
am i still that same person
[Music]
the era of myths gives way to an era of
great turmoil the continent was ravaged
by the devastating war between the
empire and the alliance
however
one nation remained unaffected by the
chaos
the kingdom of alatane
ward of the august
looked destined to have its soil stained
with the blood of battle
we've finally been called up we're up
against the empire's main arm
we are to eradicate every last imperial
who comes ashore keep focused
come on everyone
now you will die
do you really have such a yearning for
war
i can't comprehend it
[Music]
so then
what shall we do now
we're going to retake it
this is our chance while they're all
assembled
we should send our best and crush them
that's right
all the more reason to avoid bloodshed
[Music]
it also likely means that they're in
danger
i suppose it is the only way for us to
survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if the will to fight still lingers
within you
then accept my offer
and join me
[Applause]
[Music]
here's my words
ragnarok tears our world asander
only hope precious
lies on the brink of annihilation
become my tool of intervention
and save this world
[Music]
so
your efforts to remain undetected are
lacking
reveal yourself
who are you
that's all for today we'll see you soon
with another state of play
[Music]
[Music]
okay
you